the white sheets are there to keep the
outside world from looking in where the
Dutchess of Sussex is sheltering from
the Royals storm in the face of an icy
Canadian winter we now know she didn't
phone into those crisis talks 4,000
miles away from here for a couple
looking to escape there can be few
better places than this where even the
coffee shop shows off its royal colors
but where the conversations now turned
to who pays for that new Canadian life I
don't think we should have to pay for
them like security yeah
on the royalist myself but I we all work
for a living you know how do you think
they should do well if he's gonna if
they're gonna leave UK come here then do
look I did 65 years ago I could
certainly see contributing to it I'm not
sure we should be paying the whole
amount but I don't have a problem with
contributing I could see if it was sort
of divided between the Royals downtown I
think people would feel better about it
and the whole road
but who knows whatever works out we'll
just wish him the best it's a question
that's reached the Prime Minister we're
not entirely sure what the final
decisions will be where the dispositions
are and those are those are decisions
for them I think most Canadians are very
supportive of of having having Royals be
here but how that looks and what kind of
costs is involved there's - lots of
discussions de Canadiens biggest selling
newspaper has made its position clear
Royals living here it says threaten the
country's relationship with the monarchy
some of the businesses that have dealt
with a couple here say they've received
a backlash for speaking publicly about
them it tells you a lot about the desire
here to respect the couple's privacy to
give them exactly what they've come here
for the pictures they posted of the
great outdoors here have reportedly
sparked a surge in tourism a more
permanent move is far more complex and
there are reminders of home everywhere
Gregg Milam Sky News Vancouver Island